Çeviri: kübra demir
Gözden geçirme: berat güven
Merhaba.
Size daha önce hiç kimseye anlatmadığım
çok özel bir anımı anlatarak
başlamak istiyorum.
Yıllar önce “Aile Dizimi” diye bir tür
terapi seansına katılmıştım.
Svagito diye biri yapıyordu bu seansı.
Onunla bir odaya girdik ve bana dedi ki,
“Anneannenle babaanneni hatırlıyor musun?”
Ben de dedim ki, “Anneannemle
babaannemi hatırlamıyorum çünkü
anneannem, ben doğmadan önce vefat etti,
babaannem de ben doğduktan
çok kısa bir süre sonra vefat etti,
o yüzden bilmiyorum onları dedim ve
niye oradan başladığını da
bilmiyordum çünkü
onlara tutunarak nereye gidebiliriz
diye düşünüyordum, benim hiç
karşılaşmadığım bu insanlarla.
Bana dedi ki,
“Şu anda onların bu odada
olduğunu farz et ve
onlardan bahset, nasıl duydun,
onlar hakkında ne biliyorsun?”
Ben de dedim ki,
“Anneannem felsefe öğretmeniydi ve
kadınlarla mücadele konusunda
bir şeyler yaptığını biliyorum,
babaannem de şairdi.”
Sonra dedi ki, “onların şu anda
bu odada olduğunu hayâl et ve
onlara teşekkür et” dedi.
“çünkü sen hayatta ne yapıyorsan
onlardan aldın bu bayrağı ve
onlardan aldın bu emaneti ve
şu anda seninle gurur duyuyorlar.”
Ve ben ilk defa hayatımda, Beyoğlu’nda
bir binanın üçüncü katında,
bir odada diz çöküp
hiç görmediğim, hiç hatırlamadığım
anneannemle babaanneme
gözyaşları içinde teşekkür ettim.
Bunu size niye anlattım?
Çünkü o gün hissettiğim şey; bu kadınlardan
gelen bir nehrin içinde akıp gitmemdi
ve ben bununla gurur duyuyordum
bu büyük kadınlardan aldığım
mirastan ve bayraktan.
Bu tabii ki sembolik bir şeydi ama
kadın olmaktan gerçekten gurur duyduğumu
ve onlardan aldığım bu emaneti
taşıdığımı o gün çok hissettim.
Şu anda bu salonda bulunan herkes,
aslında hayatını bir kadından emanet aldı.
Ve o zaman, peki "kız gibi" kelimesi
ne zaman dandik bir şey haline geldi?
Yani, niye bir şeyi kız gibi yapmak onu
dandik yapmak oldu? Nasıl oldu bilmiyorum.
Aranızda annesinin beceriksiz olduğunu
söyleyebilecek birisi var mı?
Kelimelerin büyü olduğunu duymuştum
eskiden. Kelimeler gerçekten büyü.
Kariyerinin çok büyük bir kısmında
kelimeleri kullanan biri olarak
söyleyebilirim ki; gerçekten kelimeler
karşıdaki insana büyü yaparlar
ve biz eğer 'kız gibi' kelimesini
bir şeyi yalapşap yapmak,
'adam gibi' kelimesini de bir şeyi
doğru düzgün yapmak olarak kullanırsak;
bu o kelimeleri, o sıfatları
cinsiyet ayrımına sokmak
ve aynı zamanda 'kız gibi' kelimesiyle
karşı tarafı güçsüzleştirmek,
küçümsemek demek olur.
Peki ben bu kelimeyi
nasıl değiştirmek istiyorum?
Orkid'in sponsorluğundaki 'kız gibi'
kampanyasını görene kadar ben de
dilimdeki bu kelimenin farkında değildim.
Ben de bu kelimeleri duydum.
İlk duyduğum ve son duyduğum
zamanları size söyleyeyim:
İlk kez bir basket sahasında
duyduğumu hatırlıyorum.
Potaya basket attım, sonra birisi bana
"kız gibi attın" dedi.
Herhalde, karpuz gibi attığım içindi
ve ilk kez o zaman duymuştum.
Sanıyorum yine 13-14 yaşındaydım ve ilk
bestemi de bir kız gibi o sene yapmıştım,
zaten ruh halimi de çok iyi
anlatıyor beste, çünkü aynen şöyleydi:
(şarkı) "I see the clouds, rain is coming"
-yani herhalde görmüşüm
bir şeylerin geldiğini o yıllar-
Sonra, son kez de şeyde duydum:
Maçta bir kişi tribünden sahaya bağırdı
"kız gibi oynamayın be" diye,
futbol maçında.
Şimdi ben neden bu
kelimenin arkasında durmak istediğimi
size başka bir örnekle daha
anlatmak istiyorum. 11 yıl önce
Orkid'le 'çocuk da yaparım kariyer de'
diye bir şarkı yaptık ve bu şarkı
kadınlara bizim hiç beklemediğimiz kadar
çok özgüven aşıladı. Öyle bir şey oldu ki,
havaalanında peşimden koşup
"Nil hanım, Nil hanım sizin dediğinizi
yaptım ve 4 çocuk yaptım ama
kariyerimde zorlanıyorum" diyenler oldu.
(gülüşmeler) Ben de dedim ki:
biraz abartmamış mısınız?
Bir kere Akhisar'da bir
kız meslek lisesinin açılışına gitmiştim
orada da mikrofona çıktığımda
ne diyeceğimi bilemedim.
Bir sürü kız var karşımda ve okul açılıyor
ve ben de onlara sadece dedim ki,
yani içimden o sırada öyle demek geldi
"çocuk da yapın, kariyer de!" dedim
ve gerçekten hayatımda bu kadar tezahürat
duymamıştım, sanki kendimi Elvis Presley,
Beatles gibi filan hissettim,
çığlıklar koptu ve o gün ilk defa
birilerine özgüven vermenin ne kadar
güzel bir his olduğunu hissettim ve
gözlerim doldu, çok güzel
bir şeydi çünkü bu.
Biliyorsunuz dünyada da, Türkiye'de de
kızların çok eksik olduğu ve eksikliğini
duyduğu bir duygu özgüven ve ben şu an
aranızdan birine desem ki
bana hayat hikayenizi anlatın; muhtemelen
bu özgüven anlarından bahsedeceksiniz
çünkü insanlar özgüven duyduğu anlarda
geometrik olarak sıçrama yaparlar.
Bu yüzden kızlar için çok önemli olan
bir duyguyu "kız gibi" kelimesi soyuyor,
potansiyelimizi öldürüyor.Cinsiyetimiz niçin
bir şeyi kötü yapmak anlamına gelsin?
Ben istiyorum ki, kız gibi de
tıpkı adam gibi olduğu gibi
bir şeyi en iyi yapmak demek olsun,
bir şeyi başarmak anlamına gelsin;
biz bir şeyi kız gibi yaptığımız için
kendimizle gurur duyalım.
Dünyada yapılan araştırmalar göstermiş ki;
16-24 yaş arası kızlar, özellikle ergenlik
döneminde, %89'u bu kelimeyle yaralanıyor.
O halde, siz de buna destek olun,
bizimle beraber bu kelimeyi yaralayan
bir şey değil, kanatlandıran bir şey
haline getirelim. #kizgibi hastag'iyle
kendi yaptığınız, erkekler de yapabilirler
iyi yaptığınız bir şeyi paylaşırsanız;
fotoğraf , video ya da yazı olarak
sosyal medyada, bunu yaymamıza ve
bu kelimenin artık yeni güzel anlamını
çoğaltmamıza yardımcı olursunuz.
Dilerim hayatta ne yaparsanız
kız gibi yaparsınız çünkü ben de
(şarkı) kız gibi yaptım ne yaptıysam ben,
kız gibi yaptım ne yaptıysam.
Çok teşekkürler.